[Music]
our own dr
mark siegel took a break from his
medical practice in new york and went to
washington this morning to interview the
white house
the president rather at the white house
here's part of their conversation
mr president great news today on
vaccines against
pfizer bioentech vaccine 100 million
doses being purchased by the federal
government
for 2 billion dollars it seems like
therapeutics and vaccines are really
proceeding in a
major speed they are mark they're going
very well i watch you all the time and i
watch you're almost like my guide to
this because frankly
you really have a good take on it you
know how important it is the vaccines
are doing
well and therapeutics i mean you tell me
but i almost would prefer
the therapeutics even first you go into
the hospital you make people better
but we're doing very well with rem de
severe and other things the steroids are
turning out to be great plasma is
turning out to be really good
we've made tremendous progress and i
think that's where you see the death
numbers
is a horrible thing to say but that's
why you see the death numbers really
looking much better more on vaccines i'm
concerned about vaccine compliance in
this country
30 percent of people have said they
wouldn't even take this vaccine
as commander in chief and leader of the
free world would you consider being one
of the first to take this vaccine to
send a message to the american public
well you know the way it works if i'm
the first one they'll say he's so
selfish he wanted to get the vaccine
first
and then other people would say hey
that's a very brave thing to do
i would absolutely if they wanted me to
if they thought it was right i'd take it
first or i'd take it last month
you do know that if i take it first i'll
be either way i lose on that one right
if i take it first and if i take it if i
don't take it they'll say he doesn't
believe in the program
uh but whatever i think is best whatever
we all agree is best i would certainly
do that
i'll make your deal i'll take it and
then you will take it together that's
right good
talk to me about lockdowns i'm as you
know very disturbed about the
you you probably more than me disturbed
about the economic yeah
mental physical medical costs of
lockdowns and democratic governors are
again talking about lockdowns what's
your view
you know you can almost see it on
television i've watched some of these
guys i watched
well i won't say because it's not
somebody i have a lot of liking or
respect for but
a certain comedian that's been locked in
his house for a long period of time
and he's like withered away he's he's
lost the whole deal
he's lost the wit he's lost so much i
almost would like to use him as an
example but you can use more than just
him
it's hurting people these lockdowns are
hurting people
we did the right thing mark i don't know
if you agree but i think you do
we closed it down we understood the
disease we didn't know anything about
this this came
and this was new we understood the
disease we banned china from coming in
which was a big move in fact dr fauci
actually said
that i saved tens of thousands of lives
and if you remember i was the only one
that wanted to do it nobody
we had an office of 21 people everyone
said no but i said you got to do it
because you could see the infection in
china we banned then we banned europe
from coming in
which was good with italy and all the
problems but we did it right we closed
it up
and now we're opening and we've learned
for instance we've
learned that the elderly especially
obviously you can say this better than
anybody
the elderly who have diabetes or have
heart problems have a problem
they're really susceptible and you know
when people like to compare to the flu
it's interesting because i see the flu
numbers and they're very bad
but when i look at flu numbers and i
look i never lost anybody to the flu i
never had somebody oh
over my life i've heard many people had
the flu they had the flu
how you doing i have the flu nobody died
i never remember anybody saying
like you know he had the flu he died
i've lost five people
probably six actually as of this moment
i think pretty soon but i've lost five
friends that went in
one of them tested great guy stanley
shearer one of the top real estate
people in new york very successful man
good man too
never into politics until i ran he was
he became like a political
wild man he loved it but a great guy
with great spirit he said i tested
positive
and i said well that's too bad but
you'll be okay oh i'll be okay he went
to the hospital two days later he's in a
coma i say how's stanley doing he's in a
coma
and two days later he died and you know
that's happened on numerous occasions
probably happened to you with people too
i never remember anything like that it
didn't i mean i never
remember this happening with the flu so
this is a very serious thing but we've
learned
people stanley was an older guy
he perhaps could have lost a couple of
pounds actually i always thought of him
as healthy but other people
that are healthy the age is such a big
factor when you look
in new jersey i happen to like he's
liberal but i get along with him very
well your governor of new jersey right
governor murphy
he said they had with the thousands of
deaths
they had one death under the age of 18.
and i believe that young person had
diabetes but
one death had a thousands of people one
death
and that's an amazing statistic so we
wouldn't have known that at the
beginning
in all fairness you didn't know the
elderly would be so badly hurt
so we're really taking care of the
elderly population
right now at a level that has never
happened before
are we going to beat this virus we're
going to beat it yeah we're going to be
at it and with time you're going to be
at it
time you know i say it's going to
disappear and they say oh that's
terrible he said well it's true i mean
it's going to disappear
before it disappears i think we can
knock it out before it disappears that's
what i want
and if i had my choice of vaccines or or
therapeutics
give me therapeutics every time because
i'd love to walk into a hospital and
give everybody something and they start
walking out in two days that's what i'd
like
vaccine is very good longer term but
give me therapeutics and we're doing
really good work therapeutically